Imagine what your neighbors would say...
...if they saw you driving a vehicle like this down the street.
There's definitely a lot of James Bond appeal.
Often referred to as the flying car, the Transition is a one of a kind,...
...two passenger aircraft that can retract its wings to drive on the road.
Transforming from plane to car takes only 30 seconds.
I wanna pull up somebody's driveway and unfold the wings...
...and have an airplane in their driveway and wonder how it got there.
In both car and plane mode...
...the vehicle is powered by unleaded gasoline from a regular gas station...
...eliminating the need for pricier aviation fuel.
This will help make the Transition one of the greenest,...
...most environmentally friendly airplanes in the world.
If you can keep this thing in your garage like you can keep your SUV in your garage,...
...but you can fly through the air at twice the speed of your SUV...
...and get twice the gas mileage of your SUV.
Now that the Transition has proven it can take off and land smoothly,...
...engineers are continuing extensive tests...
...with plans to deliver the first vehicles to customers in 2011.